[Music]
j-just sign with Miami Dolphins
so I'm a single parent for the next five
months although no chaotix but in the
best way I mean I my kids are great
there are good kids for the most part us
we have our stuff but it's it actually
wasn't as hard as I thought it was gonna
be being a single parent yeah and I have
an amazing nanny I mean I just do my
mother-in-law is there with my kids
right now so I couldn't do it without
them are you moving to Miami we're gonna
stay put in Nashville we just moved
there actually a couple months ago
full-time and both my boys are in school
it doesn't make sense to pack up the
family just for five months we'll be in
Miami for all the home games but no
sorry Jay we'll see you when we see ya
that's enough hour and a half flight
okay that's very doable yeah could be
worse
but you know it's gonna be fun for the
kids once we're in Miami we're on the
beach I mean they're gonna have so much
fun the boys love going to the games so
it's hard right now because they're
still in training camp it's been hard on
my boys cuz they're old enough now they
get it you know daddy's gone but once
we're down there and you know we'll be
back and forth a lot there they're gonna
be very excited and they get an you know
they're very into football how do you
guys manage the long distance with your
marriage
um a lot of face time we have such a
great foundation I mean I trust him I
never once have to worry about him and
same for me and that helps a lot I mean
I in a lot of ways I almost think it's
better because he can just focus on
football
he's enough to worry about the kids and
whatever it may be or me and so I want
him to just take these five months and
go out there and kill it and just do a
great job it's weird because I felt like
he was retiring so what was that
decision process like for you guys it
was tough it was really tough I mean he
had you know he made up his mind he was
done and he was hanging at home and he
was with the kids and then all of a
sudden this offer came up and it was a
really hard decision for him I mean it's
it's been hard on him to be away from
the kids but he he's very excited as Jay
Cutler gets ready for his first season
with the Miami Dolphins Kristin
Cavallari is making big moves to her new
uncommon James jewelry line is
outnow collection number two yeah that's
a big deal I know I'm excited I'm fine
yeah I get to do what I want you get to
design jewelry I love and want to wear
and it's just great the modern woman
doesn't have ten minutes every morning
to try on different pieces of jewelry
we're on the go we want things to be
easy
we don't you know we don't want to think
about it and so being able to throw on
your favorite couple pieces and have
them go with every outfit and you can
wear them to work and then go get drinks
after and they work with every occasion
I think that that's really appealing
[Music]